quick come along now
look at these plastic bands of course
they're real there you go look see don't
have a look in the rock pools okay I'll
get these kills yes
lobster contains more meat per pan than
any other shellfish so it's great to
Sunday lunch so just gonna pull them
very very plainly I'm gonna leave it up
do it for about six seven minutes per
lobster do you put vinegar in there and
this is sweet and the lobster on its own
is just you know delicious and it
doesn't really need much enhancement
that instantly kills them yeah and just
for sort of putting them in boiling
water is what slow and agonizing they're
dead by then well if you want to waste
time stabbing it in their head you go
right ahead
when you separate three egg yolks with
me yeah and I'll show how to make the
perfect I only have you seen our eggs
these are our chicken they're called
Cotswolds leg bars or something or other
and they laid blue eggs and then we got
those that lay brown ones
that's David Beckham that's Sol Campbell
and Paul skulls and Rooney no because
they were named before Rooney in any way
we don't have a chicken stupid well to
make a blender with garlic mustard lemon
juice and olive oil it's so fresh it is
one of the great foods this I think this
one crab and see that little line there
yeah I'm gonna taste it that's it [ __ ]
sack you don't read that I've never
taken that out that unfortunately and
you know what you think like you come
across a piece of spinach you think
Tyson's a big Chrissy
yeah you've just gone through the
shitsack right I've got to get a crap
out of these ones now I am going to big
this on my own stuff that until just 10
minutes ago I'd have gladly eaten dirty
clothes he's full of [ __ ] yes he is I am
full of [ __ ] wouldn't it just if you run
them under attack does that knack of the
flavor yeah never never never
worst thing you ever do to lobs are
under attack yeah so when thing is
simple as delicious as this you don't
need anything complicated do you know
poached lobster a really nice salad of
watercress new potatoes and that's what
really upsets me when you see chefs the
way they over complicate a lobster nice
nice nice nice
a carriage a very small amount of
passengers cheers guys thank you I
believe the language agree to the
partner who will believe in lobster food
incredible isn't it just because you
haven't got cats here we go really
enjoying it really a superb how they
doing those onions sweat them down nice
this way now nicely yep
see the way it's all starting to break
down yeah